the Joe Rogan experience I was gonna say
on the new on the iPhone something I
didn't notice that you were getting
close to is that they added in the
health app your headphone audio levels
so it tracks how loud you're listening
to stuff over time and it tells you when
you're in a good or bad audio listening
range like if you're listening to [ __ ]
too loud you're starting to damage your
hearing whoa
so this then gets into the Apple watch
they if you turn it on on your watch it
listens to the ambient sound so if
you're in an environment like in a city
where it's too loud it adds that into
your your audio health it gives you
warnings also because one thing I've
been doing lately at the Comedy Store
when you know the backbackback place
where you smoke the weed you can
download a audio meter that tells you
how loud it is and so I've been down I
download that a long time ago it is so
bad back there when there's a lot of
people back there that it's like
emergency get out of that area it's bad
for your eyes or ears it's like a bar
yeah I know but it's way high and hired
well yeah you got a bunch of comics back
there echoes off there oh that's true
too right the concrete everything I
would say though allowing them to listen
to all these microphones you're just
giving them access to listen to you
everywhere and what do they listen you
[ __ ] there's an article that went around
these recently about this stuff called
like a mesh network that skiped created
with some of these like cameras on
people's doors there's like a test that
happened in the LA basin 700 cameras
gave them access to almost the entire LA
area
whoa because the way that they link to
each other and there's like some like
watchdog people are saying that like
even if you're smart enough to like not
do this the person next to you might not
be or your neighbor might not be they
might have it on and just because your
proximity is close enough your iPhone
knows that your iPhones next to it it
just goes yeah yeah you were here Joe
was there yeah you can't it's gonna be
really hard to pull [ __ ] off in the
future and it seems like with all these
nest phones and ring phones and or you
know not ring phones ring cameras and
net cameras nest cameras and people have
on their front doors after a while it's
everywhere you go you're gonna be filmed
they passed a law I think today that the
California
like body cameras that cops use can't be
used for facial recognition like the
ACLU got a law passed through that said
like that won't be able to happen or
something like that hmm
too bad but we're caught a lot more
people that seems that says weird
because that seems like when you would
want to use it that's when you're a cop
looking for bad guys it's like yeah but
I think what's happening right now that
I've been reading is like there's
third-party companies are getting access
to that stuff and like they can buy it
and that's where some of the discrepancy
cuz it's just happening too fast there
aren't laws in place to stop some of
these things from happening I just think
that's just a lots of gray area that can
people can maneuver in it seems to be
not people just a matter of time before
you have surveillance everywhere
everywhere you go everywhere everything
is available to everyone except inside
your house like people gonna tinfoil up
the inside of their bedrooms just to try
to keep people out and then you have the
[ __ ] television that probably has a
webcam on it you know people watching
you [ __ ] Jamie they do watch they'd
listen to the some TVs have that stuff
on to listen to what's going on in your
house and what your dick
cross-references audios let's say
serious all of that is yeah they're
listening to everything I mean even
contractors who work for Alexa in an
Apple pods and all that [ __ ] with or I
think apples one of the ones did is is
that Apple as well because apples pretty
damn strict on privacy which is kind of
interesting it's one of the reasons why
Apple Maps is not very good yeah because
they don't collect data on everybody the
way Google does like the benefit of the
Google map color of the Google data
collection is you get like really
detailed analytics on everything and so
they know exactly what's going on so why
something like Waze work so well because
there's so many different people giving
up information you know that's mean it
shows you where the slowdowns are and
where the cops are and you know it's
it's there's benefits to it it's super
effective but the drawbacks are you're
going down this weird road where these
companies are selling your information
and that's what what Google is is a
company that provides you data they
provide you information but they're also
selling your data they're constantly
selling what you're interested in
like if you ever went and like say like
you're interested in a watch like I want
to get a new watch let me look at
watches every [ __ ] time you go to any
website now those Google ads will be a
watch yeah it's weird
it's like they're they're they're just
tempting you like come on Jamie I was
listening to a podcast about the
beginning of the his the history of the
internet it's called like mint cast this
was a couple months ago but he was
talking about how like when ARPANET was
starting up in the 60s there were a lot
of protests about just even turning it
on because people were knew that it was
gonna be a surveillance system like sort
of like what is happening now really
yeah even back then and and the ability
it doesn't work if people aren't using
it kinda like it needs to spread and get
it grow and then personal computing is
sort of like tied in and came along the
perfect time for this whoo to like grow
more like phones or even the next the
next evolution of it now but doesn't it
make life better I mean there's pros and
cons right and the cons were all
terrified of but isn't it amazing that
you could just Google things yeah like
you know like I I said something the
other day that I thought was a line in
the movie I was like it's not a line in
a movie and my wife is just googling it
and just like nope no no no like what
how crazy is that you could just find
out like in a movie like how many
goddamn movies are there you just type
in something in quotes and it'll say oh
that was from The Shining
and then BAM the lyrics for every song
or then every song every song it's just
the the prose I think at least right now
outweigh the cons it's just we all
wonder where it's going that's what's
scary what's scary is the unknown you
know scary is this unknown surveillance
state aspect of it all you know it's
just it's better though it's like there
are benefits I've bought some of this
ads I've got [ __ ] for all the time great
well John Carmack had an interesting
take on that you know you know who's
Carmack is the guy who created quake and
doom and all those games and he was
talking about oculus and we were talking
about technology and people being
addicted their phones he's like yes but
it makes your life better he's like his
take on it was but people's lives are
improved because of this technology and
that this is you know
the guest people do get addicted to be
on the screens but one of the reasons
why is because it's it seems better to
them than not being on the screens like
there's benefits it's making their life
more enjoyable like okay but you're I
see how you're looking at it that way
but that's you know convenient when
you're in technology to look at it that
way but the people that look at it like
in terms of like human beings and our
connection with each other like how much
of is how much of it is getting eroded
because so much I mean how much how many
times do you and I unless we see each
other at the store how many times we
talk on the phone like I called you up
the other day okay first phone call of
2019 I just want to talk on the phone
Mac we can talk on the phone yeah I
think it's good to talk on the phone I
don't think people talk on the phone
enough I definitely don't well we're
lucky too in that our job we go out at
night and we see each other we all see
our friends you know we talk like
there's a lot of folks who don't do that
they see each other at work during the
day and then at nighttime they're
sitting at home watching TV or staring
at their phone and their interaction is
severely limited like our business is a
social business like we're always out
you know we're always out and about and
talking to people and interacting with
people but I think some folks today
because of this technology they're
socially a bit stunted and that's what I
worry about
[Applause]